leaders in government and tech want to
rewrite a law
that shapes the internet it is clear
that section 230
in its current form is no longer working
this law
needs to be updated so that it continues
to work
well i think that congress should update
the law
to make sure that it's working as
intended
section 230 is a law that governs who's
liable for what people post on social
media
but some critics say it lets platforms
censor users
or spread harmful information and should
be rewritten
most everyone agrees that it's time to
review
section 230 but there's not a lot of
consensus
about what the problems are with it or
what to do about it
to understand this debate it will help
to dissect the bill
here's the first critical passage no
provider or
user of an interactive computer service
shall be treated as the publisher
or speaker of any information provided
by another
information content provider this gives
websites the first of two key
protections
one is immunity when one of their users
posts something that might be offensive
or harmful
in that case the user is the one liable
for the speech
not the internet company that hosted it
in other words
twitter isn't liable for what people
tweet that's
different from traditional media
companies who can be sued over what they
publish
the other key protection that section
230 gives internet companies
is the freedom to moderate the content
that users upload
the freedom to moderate comes from this
passage companies that operate in good
faith have the power to restrict access
to material that they consider to be
objectionable
whether or not such material is
constitutionally protected
so if they take down a post that's
offensive or harmful
they won't be held liable for that
either it was written when the internet
was really
growing up and there were a lot of
websites out there there were a lot of
startups and
it was kind of a free-for-all in terms
of what the rules of the road were
around who could say what and who would
be liable if something
bad happened related to internet content
in the 90s
internet service providers like prodigy
were developing interactive features for
their platforms
like bulletin boards but on one of these
bulletin boards
a prodigy user wrote a post that led to
a lawsuit from an infamous brokerage
firm
called stratton oakmont you may remember
it from the wolf of wall street movie
where it was portrayed
they got involved in the section 230
story because they
sued someone who had posted something
about them online
stratton won its defamation suit in part
because prodigy had moderated its
content
which in the court's view made it a
publisher so the stratton case created
this dynamic where internet companies
had kind of a perverse
incentive if they took down a piece of
content because it was harmful
they could be sued for doing that and so
in a way they had an incentive not to do
anything to just let
people say whatever they wanted or they
could just not allow any posts
by users at all and neither of those
outcomes
seemed very beneficial to consumers and
that's why congress stepped in
senator ron wyden co-authored the 1996
text
and is said that section 230 was written
to relieve the burden on fledgling tech
companies
we wanted small businesses to start out
focusing on
hiring engineers developers and
designers
rather than worrying about how they had
to hire a team of lawyers
but since section 230 was written the
reach and political importance of
platforms has grown
and that's led to numerous calls to
update the law republicans have
challenged the legal protections that
section 230 grants
and say that the law lets tech companies
censor conservatives
here's senator roger wicker commenting
on a range of content takedowns that
occurred ahead of the 2020 election
these recent incidents are only the
latest in a long
trail of censorship and suppression of
conservative voices on the internet
reasonables or observers are left to
wonder whether big tech firms
are obstructing the flow of information
to benefit one political
ideology or agenda but platforms debate
these claims
let me be clear we approach our work
without political bias
full stop to do otherwise would be
contrary to both our business
interests and our mission if republicans
are concerned that internet
companies are taking too many posts down
democrats have the opposite concern
they're worried that internet companies
are leaving too many posts
up in particular false information about
elections or any other issue so
they really want to see these companies
be a lot more active
facebook is profiting off and amplifying
disinformation
that harms others because it's
profitable
this isn't a speech issue on the
campaign trail
joe biden said that it's time to revoke
how much protection tech platforms get
i for one think we should be considering
taking away the exemption
that they cannot be sued for
knowingly engaged on and
promoting something that's not true
others like susan ness
a former fcc commissioner say that
limiting the liability
protections in section 230 could chill
free expression
to the extent one plays around with it
too much or removes it
um we it will have a dramatic and
negative impact on freedom of expression
others question the assumption that tech
companies are acting in good faith
especially when harmful content goes
viral some lawmakers look at this issue
and say look if an internet company
takes a piece of content
and processes it puts it through an
algorithm
promotes it and helps it go viral well
in that case
maybe the company should have more
responsibility about whether that
content was harmful
others simply think the companies have
too much leeway to decide what stays up
and what comes down
one bill from senate republicans aims to
strike the otherwise objectionable
standard
and replace it with narrower guidance on
content that promotes self-harm
terrorism or unlawful activity another
area of focus is transparency
there's real mistrust among the american
people about whether you're being fair
or transparent
this is one area where tech executives
say they agree
i hear the concerns and acknowledge them
but
we want to fix it with more transparency
you know these companies really
have come to a point where they've been
under criticism for years
and they're realizing that saying hey
just keep your hands off us
isn't going to work and so they are now
advocating for some form of regulation
that they can live with
all these solutions we're talking about
are legislative and it's hard to pass
laws particularly when congress is
divided
and that means the courts could be the
first place where
section 230 changes justice clarence
thomas
issued a statement where he questioned
whether the provision has been
interpreted too broadly by the courts
and he was sort of inviting
legal challenges to section 230 and the
way that it's been interpreted
with a review of section 230 underway
the web that we know
could morph into something fundamentally
[Music]
different